[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés comme chaque semaine
nous parlons de sujets qui font
l'actualité
une mobilité plus difficile pas de
véhicule personnel ou encore des
services parfois trop éloignées selon la
situation se rendent chez le médecin
dans une médiathèque pour mary peut être
compliqué face à cela se mette en place
depuis plusieurs années des services
mobiles et c'est le choix qu'ont fait
les trois collectivités qui sont avec
nous ce soir elles sont représentées
notamment par pauline bynocchio le faire
au bon soir vous êtes vice président
délégué à la ruralité entre autres
départements des yvelines véronique
milot bonsoir adjointe au maire de la
ville de mort pad parmi vos délégations
celle aux seniors et cécile très bien
bon sens non seulement cette responsable
crp centre de ressources pour les
professionnels de l'enfance et le
bibliobus à saint quentin en yvelines
je vais commencer avec vous madame
minaucourt lefebvre puisque c'est
peut-être le bus dont 2 me dans lequel
on a le plus parlé ces derniers mois
situation sanitaire oblige pour
accélérer la vaccination contre la copie
de 19 le département a lancé le fax
eboussi sillonnaient début les zones
rurales c'était un besoin
oui il est venu combler là
il est venu s'installer à combler les
trous dans la raquette c'est ce qu'on
dit souvent du rôle du département des
yvelines là où effectivement il n'y
avait pas de centres de vaccination
parfois des centres qui était un peu
saturé ces bus dont on a le plus parlé
mais c'est pas le premier qu'on a mis en
vente ses presque le dernier que vous
avez mis en place justement ces centres
n'étaient pas toujours accessibles il
fallait aller dans des communes parfois
des petits sa couvée ça pouvait être
compliqué il a surtout permis
au début des vaccinations à des
personnes âgées de nos communes rurales
de s'inscrire et d'être vacciné plus
rapidement parce que c'est le premier à
avoir pu se faire vacciner ces personnes
âgées c'est presque un an de
mobilisation pour ces trois véhicules
oui
ça se passer correctement les les
communes se les arrachent et si le move
peut se dire non j'ai pas eu ce retour
là j'ai l'impression que ça s'est plutôt
bien passé
c'était en fait alors ça a été fait en
lien avec la rs évidemment et
c'était une offre supplémentaire et
complémentaire c'est à dire que plus on
vaccinait mieux c'était et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même pas mal
réussi la campagne de vaccination dans
notre pays et ses initiatives pense
était importante et sans doute
rassurante pour les pour les territoires
les plus ruraux alors amené les services
au plus près ou permettre aux
administrés de se déplacer le 12 avril
dernier la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux a inauguré sa vie
si net est un véhicule de six places
regardez le reportage de céline charles
c'était une promesse de campagne voisins
le bretonneux a mis en circulation ce
mardi 12 avril sa vie si navette un
minibus pour les seniors l'idée de la
vessie navette est née de la
questionnaire qu'on avait fait il ya
deux ou trois ans auprès des seniors et
puis de l'analyse des besoins sociaux
qu'on est en train de terminer qui
montrait que beaucoup de gens restés un
peu isolé parce que le déplacement intra
muros dans la commune était un petit peu
complexe la navette desservira très
rares et les mardis et les jeudis matins
dans des points stratégiques de la ville
deux allers retours sont prévus par
matinée là par exemple on est dans le
centre commercial de la grande île mais
l'arrêt suivant c'est le centre
commercial de la bretonnière pour avant
d'arriver au centre commercial du
centre-ville vous avez la poste la
mairie
centre culturel decauville vous
l'apprendrez puisse arrêter quelque part
est allé faire une promenade à pied à
l'autre bout de la commune je pense par
exemple à la croix de bois une façon
pour la commune de lutter contre l'
isolement chez les plus âgés on sait
qu'il ya des gens isolés de parts soit
parce qu'ils connaissent pas grand monde
soit parce que ils n'ont pas de moyen de
déplacement la façon dont la ville est
faite fait que les gens vivent beaucoup
au fait recentrer sur leur quartier et
c'est aussi l'occasion pour des vies si
noah qui le souhaitent pas de connaître
un petit peu mieux leur commune en se
promenant de quartier en quartier pour
l'instant le minibus n'en est qu'à son
stade d'essai les horaires et le trajet
vont être adaptés en fonction des
retours des utilisateurs pour bénéficier
de la navette il suffit de se rendre sur
l'un des arrêts desservis le service est
pour l'instant gratuit jusqu'à fin juin
alors c'est un service qui existe depuis
le mois de janvier à maurepas véronique
milot c'est navette électrique elle
s'appelle abel boucle est ce que vous
avez fait le même ouvre constat que la
ville de voisins-le-bretonneux il
fallait aller au plus près de ceux qui
sont parfois un peu plus loin tout à
fait donc j'ai dû effectivement elle
porte le nom de la belle boucle elle a
été le nom a été choisi par notre
conseil désigné projet travailler en
collaboration avec eux donc l'idée
effectivement nous il ya 22 arrêts donc
on a essayé d'identifier chaque quartier
pour que voilà chaque senior puisse
avoir un point d'accès et donc
effectivement l'idée ses desserts bien
les centres d'intérêts tels que les
centres commerciaux et les cabinets
médicaux le centre ugly le marché etc
c'était une demande des administrés ou
où c'était ça vient aussi des élus tout
à fait donc historiquement il existait
sur notre ville le transport des anges
donc c'était plutôt un transport à la
demande voilà on arrière et orienté par
une navette qui circulent ou trois
matinées par semaine à raison de trois
boucles donc voilà il ya des erreurs
défini pour le coup il ya aussi on
demande également une inscription en
amont voilà puisque pour emprunter la
navette il faut être détenteur du
passeport seniors voilà ça rentre dans
toute une politique seniors qu'on essaie
d'inculquer sur martin c'est parfois la
population la plus isolée mais
population des seniors tout à fait et
par rapport à ça on a aussi un gros
travail de communication pour faire
connaître ce service puisque les seniors
isolés balla n'ont pas forcément accès à
l'information donc on est actuellement
toujours en cours sur ce travail de
communication de faire connaître le
service pour
davantage d'usagés et sortir les seniors
du coût de leur isolement alors ya la
mobilité la santé l'isolément est aussi
la culture qui se déplace à saint
quentin en yvelines il y a le pipeline
bus sa suppléante peu les médiathèques
oui alors le bibliobus a vocation à
porter l'offre du réseau des
médiathèques dans les quartiers éloignés
des équipements dur desdites médiathèque
voilà donc nous proposons le même type
de document que vous trouvez dans les
médiathèques donc livres romans albums
enfin tout voilà dvd cd
pour que chacun puisse avoir accès donc
à cette offre c'est un bus qui trouve
son public c'est un bus qui trouve son
public nous essayons d'associer dans la
mesure du possible des tournées scolaire
donc le bus entre dans une école et puis
les enfants peuvent prendre des
documents dans le cadre d'un projet
scolaire et puis ensuite le bus va
stationner donc pour sa desserte
publique donc il fait le lien entre
l'école les familles voilà oui c'est
peut-être le rendez vous juste après
l'école les enfants vont voir les
parents les pousse peut-être aussi
s'était amené les adulent finance reste
à choisir jeunes oui c'est tout à fait
ça c'est effectivement les adultes sont
souvent très pressé de les enfants une
appétence naturel pour le livre le bus
aussi donc comme ils le connaissent bien
par le truchement de l'école il y amène
effectivement la fra saur leurs parents
pauline vino pour le faible donc la
santé on l'a dit c'est le vaccin bus
mais il ya aussi le bus santé notamment
du 25 au 29 avril il ya la semaine
européenne de la vaccination y a pas que
le creux vide comment sont déterminés
les communes qui accueille justement ces
services on parler de la ruralité aussi
un manque peut-être de médecins sur
place
oui tout est un peu connecté il ya
effectivement les communes rurales qui
sont les plus isolées et dans lesquelles
les populations les plus vulnérables qui
n'ont pas forcément les moyens de se
déplacer ne peuvent pas accéder à ces
services et les quartiers
politique de la ville sont également des
cibles et et pour rejoindre ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure nous on a le premier
but ce qu'on a mis en place dans les
yvelines c'était le bus pmi donc on est
tout à fait en termes de génération à
l'autre bout au début de la chaîne si
j'ose dire et c'était pour pour répondre
dans les zones rurales et les quartiers
politique de la ville aux difficultés
que pouvaient avoir les populations
concernées donc en l'occurrence les
mairies les très jeunes enfants à se
déplacer et se rappelons le la
destruction à ghardaïa un fonds destiné
notamment à suivre le développement et
la croissance des enfants de 0 à 6 en
août accompagné la parentalité qui n'est
pas toujours très facile exactement et
c'était pour répondre à ceux à ce besoin
là quand quand parfois des structures en
dur alors pour le coup non léon les
complètent pas avec le muc pemis et
quand les structures en dur ne sont pas
pertinentes parce que trop peu utilisé
on s'est dit que d'aller au plus près
elles sont peu utilisés en plus et puis
par des publics de toute façon même si
une structure en dur de communes plus
loin ne peuvent pas s'y rendre donc le
bus répondait à ces problématiques en
allant au plus près des habitants dans
les zones les plus rurales
véronique milot donc depuis mois de
janvier il est en place il a trouvé son
public ce blitz oui comme en fait avant
le précédemment il existait une navette
qui s'appelait le jeudi déjà qui
permettait aussi de se rendre au
cimetière donc voilà historiquement le
jour a été repris entre autres il y
avait déjà ce public-là qui était ciblé
et puis ensuite vous voilà on a fait
connaître le service on s'aperçoit voilà
que outre le cimetière les seniors ce
que rendent également dans les centres
commerciaux
voilà 139 euros mary j'imagine exact
chez le médecin il ya huit centres
médicaux sur la commune café oui tout à
fait et on dessert également le centre
médical de la ville d'à côté voilà qui
concerne la pénurie de médecins de qu'on
a essayé d'élargir au maximum
voilà la boucle pour permettre l'accès
la ville de voisins vient juste de se
lancer se laisse le temps de voir
comment ça prend est-ce que vous avez
déjà évolué sur le nombre d'arrêts sur
la fréquence vous voulez c'est peut-être
encore quelques mois parce que c'est
d'être un peu court oui oui là ça fait
donc trois mois on va là que le service
est en place début mai on fait un point
notamment avec le conseil désigné qui
circule aussi au sein de la navette qui
interroge les usagers pour avoir le
ressenti est donc voilà disais c'est
aussi peut-être de rageux certes
certaines choses peut-être de décaler
sur un jour où il ya moins de
fréquentation sur un autre jour enfin on
va réadapter pour répondre au mieux aux
besoins des usagers apolline d'unocal
faible j'avais prévu de parler du plu et
la pmi mais un but comme ça ça permet
aussi de
donner aux yvelinois montrer ce dont
auxquels ils ont droit c'est pas du tout
français ce que je veux dire mais des
deux roues et kelly doivent avoir cédé
il appelle et on se rend pas
nécessairement compte c'est pour aussi
un peu tout oui c'est pas impossible
vous avez raison alors c'est parce si
vous descendez circuler nos bus ils sont
logoté département des mines ils sont
très rose comme le département des
yvelines
et peut-être que ça les rend plus
visible je pense notamment aux bus jobs
insertion mais aussi un bus qu'on a
lancé il ya quelques temps et
qui en lien avec notre agence
d'orientation activity sillonnent les
territoires les plus ruraux et quartiers
politique de la ville en priorité et
c'est vrai que ce but et c'est ce qu'ils
m'ont dit quand tu allé le voir
quand il s'est installé pour la première
fois sur mon canton il était garée sur
la place du village en plein milieu et
il paraît qu'il ya des voitures qui
passaient une fois qu'ils passaient deux
fois et puis qui finissaient par
s'arrêter pour aller voir ce qu'il y
avait là dedans parce que ça les
intrigues s est ce gros engin posé au
milieu du village avec du rose partout
et c'est vrai que ça les rend plus
visible et qui peuvent trouver un
certain nombre de pistes de réponses à
leurs questions alors pour le bus pardon
jobs insertion en terme d'emploi et
d'insertion et de démarches
administratives également oui en forme
et aussi c'est peut-être du côté de la
culture la mission du bibliobus rendre
compte aussi de tout ce que font les
médiathèques et de tout ce qu'on trouve
parce qu'au final le bus ne se déplace
pas bien sûr avec tous les fonds mais
les gens peuvent réserver ça peut faire
le drive aussi voilà c'est ça oui les
tout le monde peut réserver sur les
documents sur l'ensemble du réseau et
pour les usagers du bibliobus de faire
acheminer leurs réservations
jusqu'à la desserte qui les intéressent
ensuite ils peuvent rendre les documents
dans n'importe quelle médiathèque ou des
documents d'autres médiathèque dans le
bus il ya c'est vrai même interconnexion
tu as fait mal classés entre elles voilà
oui et puis il est bon il est pas en
service pendant les vacances scolaires
noire joint ya une petite interruption
des tournées c'est pas pour aller au
garage parce qu'il ya une opération bien
particulière il est aussi intégré dans
les animations des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines oui il intègre la
fla donc la participation la
manifestation estivale partir en livre
qui a lieu du 22 juin au 24 juillet et
cette année cette manifestation est
organisée notamment par le réseau des
médiathèques et les manifestations vont
avoir lieu dans tous les quartiers de
l'ensemble de la ski pour que pour être
au plus près des habitants
et donc c'est une manifestation qui a
pour but de favoriser la lecture pour
les jeunes la pratique de la lecture
mais aussi la pratique de l'écriture
enfin tout ce qui se rapporte à la
culture bien sûr et donc le bus va aller
dans les différentes villes et
travailler en collaboration avec les
équipes des médiathèques locales pour
proposer évidemment des espaces de
lecture mais également des des heures du
conte des séances de kamishibaï et
toutes les animations qu'on peut trouver
habituellement aux 100g des médias taxe
en plus d'autres jeux un petit peu voit
la police binod pour le faire donc on a
vu celui qui était le plus visité le
maxi bus est-ce que ça a permis aussi de
redéfinir les besoins des yvelinois ces
cinq bus qui circulent avec ses
thématiques si différentes ça fait
évoluer aussi les besoins le département
imaginent d'autres mobilité de service
on sait que c'est un outil qui
fonctionne et qui est pertinent parce
qu'il touche des populations contout
serait pas forcément avec des moyens
plus traditionnels
il al'avantage de ne pas être endurées
de pouvoir s'adapter aux besoins c'est
que si on s'aperçoit qu'ils un arrêt qui
est pas utile ou qui est pas
suffisamment utilisé on peut changer la
cartographie etc cette souplesse là je
pense est appréciable pour nous parce
que ça permet de réajuster quand ça
marche pas ça permet de renforcer quand
ça fonctionne bien a contrario
donc c'est un outil d'une ce sont des
outils d'une grande souplesse et qui met
parfois un peu de temps à se faire
connaître il faut passer là l'étape de
rentrer dans le bus mais
voilà une fois que s'est installée que
c'est connu et que ça fonctionne c'est
vraiment bénéfique pour nous pour nos
communes une souplesse de masina
précieux c'est pas sur la commune de
maurepas on peut évoluer en fonction des
besoins de chacun c'est prévu exactement
exactement à faire un point voilà c'est
peut-être des centres d'intérêt qui sont
plus prisées que d'autres des jours de
la semaine et c'est l'idée voilà c'est
n'est pas restée figée de s'adapter au
plus près des mesures imaginées un autre
public touché les personnes à mobilité
réduite peut-être un jour sans c'est pas
le choix qu'on a fait après le bus est
accessible dans des personnes en
fauteuil roulant peuvent l'emprunter
mais voilà pour l'instant une fois
détenteur du passeport seniors alors
plus de soixante deux ans de sidération
vraiment destiné à ce public là je
propose comme s'arrête sur ces mots pour
toutes les trois toutes les informations
se trouvent sur les sites qui sont qui
ont été diffusées à l'antenne pendant
toute cette émission merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation
vous l'avez compris c'est une société
maintenant a terminé merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
pourrait changer
je
[Musique]
faux
vous
[Musique]